[Music]  people call me a princess  but behind the palace gates and in the  shadow of my sister  the soon to be queen it was me  the second born who was chosen to  protect  our kingdom  good morning class we are going to have  fun  this summer as members of  the secret society of second-born royals  you guys have super powers  uh we're superheroes  there's a special gene exclusive to  second borns of royal bloodlines  a gene that gives some of us  extraordinary abilities  your abilities are unique to you alone  this test is designed to help sharpen  your super senses  does that involve push-ups i have a  doctor's note for that oh  yeah you're definitely not gonna like it  for thousands of years  second bones like you have protected our  kingdoms from threats he wants the  throne  he's more powerful than any of us but  he's not more powerful than all of us  royalty by day bureau by night  it sounds pretty dope  where the fairy tale ends is where our  story begins  [Music]  you